it's time for cruise news your good news
milkshake so thick it's tough to get up
that straw and with me at the desk is my
main newsman ross matthews hi drew hi
everybody hi hi
all right first up we have got a new
sister in uggs rolling stone reports
that cher is cozying up in a new
campaign for ugg boots she slipped into
a pair for an intimate tour of her home
and shared insights on her life she said
people have always either hated or loved
me
and she says that if you want to be
loved but at some point it's like four
kit you either do or don't except she
didn't say four she did not say fork uh
i love she says that people either love
her or don't love her i love share hi
share have you you got a clover too
always have you ever met
oh i knew it i knew i would ask you if
you'd met cher and you'd say yes tell me
yes everything well she was friends with
my godmother and so i was like raised
around her kids and would see her coming
and going and i don't think that there's
a bigger share fan out there actually
that's not true i do know a lot of
sheriff share is
everything yeah everything and every
iteration of cher you know what's funny
though i don't picture cher in ugg boots
i feel like she walks around her house
in like boots
like boots food like like boots yeah
like look at her i mean she is just
she's so wonderful i wish her all
the happiness and joy that she has
brought to everyone over all of these
decades
and right
i i like seeing her
in her new cozy look you know because
every look that cher has ever done
in her life gets an a plus thank you
gold star thank you she goes from bob
mackie to uggs but she can do no wrong
thank you for sharing
that story i have to tell you something
one time share followed me on twitter
for like five minutes i think it was a
gay assistant and then it went away but
i was freaking out it was the best five
minutes of my life i mean it would be a
live stream to have sure even know
you're alive completely
and and share as a personal message um
to you
from me i just want you to know that i
think you're the greatest
and the world would not be the same
without you and we're celebrating every
single thing you do
and um i already loved uggs so you just
made me love them more buying stars
and uggs
love you share
all right next up you know that after jk
simmons you all know him won an oscar
for whiplash there he is well there's
new pictures of him that have been
heating up the internet the 67 year old
actor is apparently totally completely
ripped look at those pictures the daily
mail reports jk's been hit in the gym
for years he was in first inspired back
in 1997 when he saw himself on the first
season of oz and realized he needed to
get in shape for the role but in 2009
that's when he hit 250 pounds as high
and he made it a personal vow to be in
better shape for the rest of his life uh
jk uh haha
look at him good and right now he's in
that being the ricardo's movie he's
playing fred from uh i love lucy member
the actor and he's getting oscar buzz
for that 67 years old and he has muscles
i mean girl that means it's not too late
for me i can get a nap one day
if i keep working
it's so funny like i don't know if i
would recognize him from that picture
like he's the dad in juneau
he won the academy award for whiplash
he's the in the farmer's uh insurance
commercials and he's the voice of the
yellow eminem did you know that i did
not know yeah that's him that's him yeah
and he's so good in whiplash i was so
happy when the academy award so yeah it
goes to show you 67
and busting guns like that i know i
guess there is just no excuses for
anyone i know let's all join it's 20 22
our year i'm gonna look i'm great now
i'm getting it yeah
maybe we could do the news while doing
like reps well someone give me a
dumbbell will you be a dear somebody
thank you
i'm like right here at your service
dumbbell
all right next up for those who love to
travel do you ever get your airbnb and
realize it's not quite exactly like the
pictures
well this happened to one woman on her
new york city trip
big time this is so crazy you guys food
and wine reports that desiree rose baker
booked a room right in the heart of
times square only to discover that her
window opened up into a japanese
restaurant oh hi
she didn't look into a japanese
restaurant she shared a window with the
japanese restaurant
she lifted the shade expecting to see
the skyline but found two people eating
sushi instead that is hilarious okay
ross what's the weirdest thing you've
ever found traveling nothing like this i
will i mean do you know how thrilled i'd
be i like can i get some spicy tuna
thank you so much but they just need to
market it as room service
there you go or just a warning just a
warning
you know occupation like don't they ask
like how many how many guests you know
they should just say like it'll be you
and a couple of diners exactly right
there i i've only done airbnb one time
and it was like fabulous i had this
little cabin in the smoky mountains and
i went to dollywood and it was like the
best vacation ever i've been pigeon
forged tennessee yeah i had the turkey
leg of my life in dollywood i still
think about it every day yeah
all right well next up here's a big
topic for debate all right today our
question is not when you should take
down your christmas lights but if you
should take them down at all um stylist
reports more people are boldly leaving
their lights a glowing year-round i
don't know how i feel about this experts
say the warm glow of the lights actually
boosts your mood and actually science
evolutionary fact our ancestors used to
sit around a warm fire at the end of the
day just to enjoy a meal
but um leaving your christmas tree up
all year is not okay in my book one time
i was dating somebody true story and i
went to their house it was august and
their christmas tree was up in the
middle of the living room and i was like
well what's what's that about and he
goes oh it's been up for five years i
was like i have to go
because
because i'll tell you why if you can
get used to seeing a christmas tree in
your house year-round then you probably
avoid issues in your relationship
am i right it's actually glowing at you
every day
and you're just ignoring it
red flag bye-bye um show of hands whose
christmas tree is still up
well um
you it's not august it's still you get a
pass in general i think january
absolutely like january 31st should be
the cut off but it's true the warm glowy
lights um they do they boost my mood
yeah
the end of january it's got to go though
or we have an issue how about keep the
lights lose the tree
uh middle ground i'll meet you there
understood all right i found the happy
middle all right
[Music]
you